Okay. Now, of course, the answer is a bunch of
hex characters that I'm not going to type here, but I'll go
ahead and show you in the terminal. Here I've imported
hash, hashlib. hashlib.sha256 of the string udacity, returning the hex digest,
is this big long string here. So, if you did
this, now you know how to take hashes of, of simple
strings. And, of course, you can send more than simple strings
in here. And get a hash that in this particular case,
it is 256 bits long. This is the hex
representation so obviously it's not that many characters. Of course
you can put whatever you want in here and the
output will be 256 bits cause that's what sha 256
does, and of course if we were to change our
string just in the slightest, we get a totally different
hash outlook, so we can use this technique now to
solve some problems we are having in our cookie application.